hi I'm Nick Gillespie for reason TV
today I'm talking to Timothy Pete Carney
the author of obamanomics how Barack
Obama is bankrupting you and enriching
his Wall Street friends corporate
lobbyists and union bosses to him thanks
for coming hey thanks for having me
let's start off with the top of the
title obamanomics I'm pronouncing that
right yeah okay define obamanomics
obamanomics is expanding the government
control over the economy but doing it in
concert with business in other words
people like to throw around the word
communist for obama but he's not killing
businesses he's saying look if you're
willing to play the green energy game
you'll get subsidized you'll get kept
alive will regulate you but will also
bail you out and give you hand out and
so he's delivering on more government
control over the economy that he
promised but he also promised to kill
the special interests and my argument is
he's not doing that great government is
propping up the special how is that in
the book and I think I know the answer
to this but is this a continuation of
Bush policies or it is areas at a 180
degree now it is it is Bush handed him
the keys to the bulldozer and he's
shifted into the next gear without
without the 700 billion dollar bailout
what he really have gotten away with a
787 billion dollar stimulus bill now he
and you in the foreword by Ron Paul the
congressman ran for president uh buta
tha's a libertarian back in nineteen
eighty eight and then again in this in
2008 the the term corporatism comes up
what we're seeing here is really
corporatism not capitalism and not
socialism exactly the you look at the
global warming policies there's some
there's there's a liberal way to do this
I mean a left-wing socialist way to do
that but that's not what we're getting
we're getting subsidies if you if you
have the right energy sources a
cap-and-trade system where the right
company can get very rich so profit is
still part of it it's just it's a
government calling the shots as to how
your profit as opposed to market forces
what you talk about the big myths what
is being brother think the big myth is
the idea that
big business just wants to be left alone
I mean a lot of people say there's
regulators and then there's business and
they're they're constantly battling but
occasionally reporters will notice in an
interesting twist Walmart wants this
mandate that you buy health insurance
for your employers and another
interesting twist Philip Morris wants
regulation of tobacco and it's not an
interesting twist when it keeps
happening again so yeah why why does a
big business blonde big regulation well
I call them the laws of obamanomics and
one of the first is that it when
Congress is crafting rules or regulators
are crafting the roles that the
lobbyists will get a seat at the table
and who has the lobbyists who really
have that seat it's not mom and pop it's
bigger business so government
intervention gives an opportunity for
tweaking the rules but probably the most
basic is the notion that government adds
to overhead it adds to the cost of doing
business when there are more regulations
and more taxes and so that has a bigger
impact on the smaller business than it
does on the big so Walmart gets new
costs if there's new mandates but those
costs fall much heavier on the smaller
employee so this is when sarbanes-oxley
the accounting rule overhaul came out of
his big business head was fine with that
I mean they you know maybe they weren't
fine with it but they could soak up the
extra cost whereas it would really hurt
smaller comp and there are some big
venture capital funds that got all sorts
of great acquisitions from companies
that were public and didn't want to be
public anymore on after sarbanes-oxley
talked a bit specifically about how the
big myth plays out in relation to pharma
and health care oh yeah Obama ran for
president running an ad beating up Billy
Tauzin he was a Democrat than a
Republican in Congress now he became the
drug industry lobby after helping write
a Medicare drug bill that was very
favorable to the drug makers Obama
rightly pointed this out as a problem
but then in August he Obama's chief of
staff cuts a deal with toes an in which
the promises not to go after the White
House promises not to go after the
special favors the drug bill itself has
all sorts of subsidies the health care
bill has subsidies for the drug makers
but Obama makes it sound like he's
battling against money to interest
everybody who's on the other side oh
you're a shill for the health and
straight here's a question for you does
capitalism or free markets I mean all of
this corporatism big government it all
exists it needs money to fuel itself and
yeah you know free markets I think we
agree would you know tend to do better
they produce more they generate more
income and hence more taxes in some way
does capitalism beget corporatism this
is this is a schumpeter arguing that
when you create a class of people that
can do but also the capitalism allows
some businesses to get big enough to the
point where they look out on the
capitalist market where you know the
mightier cast down and the lower lifted
up and they say we need to protect
ourselves from this and so I wouldn't
say it begets it but it's once you get
people getting lots of money and you
have a democracy like we have that has
the power as it has then it's going to
be really tough to fight we'll talk a
little bit about because towards the end
of your book this is not a doom and
gloom scenario I mean or you I mean
you're calling attention to things but
then you say there are ways to rollback
Obama nomics what what are the ways that
we stop this well one one thing that has
me hopeful is that now that the
Republicans are so far out of power
they're even losing their big business
donors this might allow them to be freed
up to kind of get back to limited
government roots and I think that they
can use something of a populist message
and I know a lot of libertarians are
uneasy with the idea of a populist
message although I mean you rightly
point out I mean you call you talk you
call for a libertarian populism Ron Paul
certainly fits the example in a certain
way so talk a little bit about how a
kind of libertarian populism can roll
back some of these I just say look we
are going to undo the bailout any money
that's not loaned out we're going to
take it back and any money that's
already out there we're going to speed
up when you have to give that back what
position does that put barack obama in
saying no we need to spend send more
money over to wallstreet and with the
drug makers you can do this go after
some of those deals at the left wants to
go after join forces with them again
sort of the corporatist in both parties
and say look we're going to take away
your special favors and make and drive
down prices is that and this is slightly
a different topic but
you know how important is public outrage
in terms of changing laws because the
the tarp bailout was not popular the
auto bailout initially was not popular
and is getting less popular the stimulus
is not particularly you know people
don't think it's helping the economy
health care reform is unpopular these
things seem to just keep going like a
steamroller so does the average work or
how do you affect political change well
i think that there's some things i mean
public outrage could affect health care
members going back for christmas who
knows what they're going to hear in the
house there's enough vulnerable
democrats just to talk about the current
situation right now enough vulnerable
democrats that if there's enough
opposition these people will be afraid
so obviously you look at the bailout i
mean the wall street belt that was
overwhelming public opposition and it
didn't matter pass overwhelmingly in
both chambers so it's not an easy game
but and one of the other problems of
sort of free market populism is where do
you get your money from republicans have
been raising from 18t from big
businesses and but I think Ron Paul
shows the answer to that where once
people who feel disenfranchised and they
see this guy's actually not on the other
side you can raise lots of money in
those fifty dollar increments and Obama
just cuz he put on that garb he was able
to raise money from regular people
because they actually believed he wasn't
going to be cozy or the special election
so in a way I mean what you're calling
for is a decentralization of political
power that would be similar to a kind of
decentralization of a lot of cultural
and economic power I mean in an Internet
age and a more spread out in a networked
place yeah I think that the the models
of the Republican and Democratic parties
built around these big concentrations of
wealth for raising funds I'm hopeful
that that will become less important and
I think both Obama and Ron Paul their
campaigns showed that showed you know
what what that can do well I want to
thank Timothy P Carney author of abala
nomics how Barack Obama is bankrupting
you and enriching as Wall Street friends
corporate lobbyists and union bosses for
talking to reason TV today I'm Nick
Gillespie thank you very much thank you
you